she's gotta be done July's change
organizations guy [ __ ] yeah
organization
it might change the world
and it is my delight to bring up our
next speaker Maile Lusaka before the GSB
she worked in consulting as well as at
Caribou Coffee
after the GSB for her summer internship
she is headed to Amazon Maile welcome so
I'm looking up at the upper left level
and I see column by himself and I'm
wondering if he's a little bit lonely
maybe but luckily a Katrina in Rome we
have joined him so it's feeling good and
I see an buyer in the back and I'm
thinking about accounting and how I
actually found out I liked it when I
thought I was gonna hate it and I see my
house for next year and my boyfriend and
then a lot of faces I don't know my name
is Maile and I have ADHD I also have
allergies so apologies if I sniffle
during the presentation but what I want
to talk to you today about is just a
couple things one what's it like to have
ADHD - good news most people with ADHD
by the time you get to be my age we know
how to deal with it and what those ways
you deal with it are and then the part
that I think is gonna matter to each and
every one of you is how when you manage
someone that has ADHD how you can
maximize that relationship so first
what's it like to have ADHD well there's
some good and there's some bad and I'm
gonna get the bad out of the way first
so when you have ADHD social
relationships are actually kind of hard
because let's say I was trying to bond
with Jenna right now I'm supposed to
look her in the eye and and ask her
questions and show interest but I'm
thinking about my legs shaking and I
kind of want to scan the room and I'm
not creating that one-on-one connection
that's so important to forming those
bonds and when you have ADHD you're
forgetful any of my friends can attest
to this but in terms of like school and
work it takes me if I don't like a task
it takes me a little bit longer to do it
and then I will forget the homework
assignment in my room and when you have
ADHD communication is hard so I'm
thinking and the words that are coming
out of my mouth are there behind the
where the words and the point is your
words get jumbled because your minds
going faster faster than you can speak
but when you have ADHD it's actually not
all bad you see there's some awesome
things about ADHD
when you have ADHD you're really
high-energy here you're up here and that
can be fun right and when you have ADHD
although you don't focus on everything
when you find something that you're
excited about and you focus you are
hyper focused I joked that I have an
addiction to romance novels and if I'm
reading one of those Tom can poke me Tom
my boyfriend forty five times and I'm
not gonna look up I am in the book and
when you have ADHD you're not a linear
thinker so most people go A to B to C
and when you have ADHD we spend time on
Z and Q and R and that's okay because
it's actually kind of fun and creative
and you're not tied to what's rational
so now that I've told you a bit about
what it's like to have ADHD how many of
you think you might know someone that
has it very good I'd raise your hands
the truth is everyone probably knows
someone that has ADHD seven percent of
the u.s. population is diagnosed with it
and the crazy thing is that numbers
actually under diagnosed because women
and high achievers find ways to work
around it and we do find ways to work
around things most of the time I joked
that my best protection against credit
fraud is the fact that I lose my wallet
at least two or three times a year I
always get new numbers no chance but I'm
gonna get an identity stolen but other
things like with the with me being
forgetful we make lists I make so many
lists in fact I have my main points of
my talk on my hand just so I don't
forget anything important and that
social thing I told you about earlier so
I was a brat when I was younger really
really a brat and got invited to nothing
and my dad he's a child psychiatrist was
like hmm what can I do about this it
probably makes sense that I'm talking
about ADHD given the heath child
psychiatrist
anyways instead of giving up on me I
remember there's this birthday party and
birthday parties were huge deal for me
because as an annoying child they were
the only things I got invited to because
everyone had to be invited to the
birthday party you guys probably
remember that so I was at this birthday
party and I couldn't drive I was in
fifth grade I still so my dad was there
he was watching on the sidelines and I
remember
he told me before I went in he might
pull his ear and if he pulled his ear
that was just a signal that maybe I
wasn't validating someone and I'm
talking I'm chatting with this girl and
all the sudden I see this and it was a
huge turning point for me because I
could suddenly connect um what he meant
he said you're not validating I didn't
know what that meant and then I suddenly
saw and it was the beginning of a new
Maile a Maile that could connect
socially and today it might seem like it
was very I guess micromanaging of my
parents but I am so thankful that they
took the time to give me these signals
because now I have great friends and
they're in the audience today thank you
all so much and I'm so so happy for that
so my point is when you have ADHD you
learn to deal with it
mostly I say mostly because the working
environment is still a new arena and the
inspiration for this talk actually comes
from a pretty personal place when I
started my first job out of undergrad at
a consulting firm I think I was a little
confusing for my manager I bit my nails
I talked too fast I didn't always speak
but when I spoke I interrupted sometimes
and and my presentations were not not
that good and I remember I think he just
threw up his hands I remember one day I
walked by his office and he said Maile
come in and I walked in and he said
honestly you're working really hard at
presenting and you're getting a little
better but if it's that hard for you
maybe you should just find a job where
you don't have to present and that was
hard but it doesn't have to be that way
and all managers haven't not known what
to do with me in fact when I was at
Caribou my manager Michelle brought out
more in me than I didn't even know what
was there and so what I want to share
with you all today are just four C's
since we all love frameworks so much
four C's that can help you deal with
someone that has ADHD and really
maximize your relationship with them so
the first C I'm going to tell you about
is coaching you probably picked up on
this but when you have ADHD you can
learn to be different than you are and
so Michelle really invest she called on
her inner coach and she really invested
in coaching me
and I remember she do things like after
every single meeting where I had to talk
she just give me one minute of feedback
like when you did this with your arm it
was really distracting and that was
really helpful right the other thing she
did to help with me not getting my words
mixed up when I communicated was five
minutes before a meeting that I was
presenting at I just run through the
headlines of my slides and before you
knew it within the first year I suddenly
didn't need her coaching anymore but her
investing in me was very important in
getting me to the place where I could
give big company presentations to get
people energized about our new product
line and I didn't have to worry about
fumbling another coaching thing Michelle
did that was really helpful was at
Caribou it was a cube system and they're
really noisy boys and they pop up over
there cubes and they throw a football
and they yell Maile and every time I did
they did that I would be distracted for
like twenty or thirty minutes really not
productive
Michelle was like Lady go get yourself
to a phone booth go where you won't be
distracted and work there and that was
really helpful she coached me on how to
minimize the chaos in my life and so my
first see for you all is coaching think
about bringing out your inner coach my
second C is clarity if you tell a person
that has ADHD to do something whenever
you get to it or after the next task I
can promise you we are not going to get
it done and then you'll be frustrated
and it just won't be good what works
much better is saying get this done by
Friday and so when you have someone with
ADHD give them clarity about deadlines a
trick that Michelle and I worked on was
I would make a list at the beginning of
each work week of every single task I
was gonna do big and small and um I I
would send them to Michelle at least for
the first year I think I stopped after
that but she didn't actually micromanage
me with them but the discipline of
putting myself to a list actually help
me execute much better than I had been
before and so your second my second see
for you is clarity think about providing
it find ways to provide clarity now
clarity and coaching those both deal
with leverage minimizing the downsides
of ADHD but this part of my talk the
last two C's are really about how you
can maximize the upsides cuz there are
some
the third sees creativity and you know
how I told you in the beginning that
when you have ADHD you're not a linear
thinker think about how useful that can
be in a business context put in person
with ADHD in charge of leading a
brainstorm or at least have them at the
brainstorm and those blue sky projects
where you want to come up with a really
innovative solution that's not based on
really anything that's come before it
that's where we're really good and use
us there so the third sees creativity
the fourth sees my favorite and that's
catalyst when you have ADHD you've got a
lot of energy and you've got a lot of
potential and you as a manager should
think about using the person with ADHD
as a catalyst in your organization
there's two main ways I think about this
the first is energy when you have ADHD
you're up and you're you're bringing
people along with you and so you know
those projects the kind of drag at work
and you don't want them to end think
about deploying the person with ADHD on
that project and seeing if they can add
a certain spunk that wasn't there before
and then the last is the last thing that
you can use them as a catalyst is you
know I said we can hyper focus if you
put us on a project we like think about
how useful that is Michelle my boss that
I loved put me on snack food I'm
obsessed with eating I do it most of my
life and I know what I should have my
own I do snack food I had a whole
strategy written brand a new product
picked out within two weeks and then the
orders place and then we roll it to
stores within six weeks after that and
retail that's a fast turnaround time and
the reason that could happen is because
I was still passionate about what I was
working on so with that those are the
four C's coaching clarity creativity and
catalyst and you know from my dad
pulling his ear and teaching me how to
interact socially to Michelle helping me
navigate the working world
I think these four C's could actually be
hugely useful for people with ADHD and I
hope that you can share them one day
with someone that has it furthermore as
I got to thinking about it some of the
C's actually seem quite they just seem
like good management and so I offer them
up to you as that as well thank you
you